Okay, Luke says, what do you do for photos on the site before selling the site? I have to get a photo from somewhere
I don't want to get sued. Do you recommend about it? Yeah, I've done stock photos. You could find nice stock photos
It's like dude. Do you pay 10 bucks 15 bucks for a photo? It's not that much money
Even if you put 10 of you know, 150 bucks, it's not much. I do stock. I do pexels.com. I do Pixlr
Just some of these free image sources, right?
It's and I know it kind of gets hard if you're doing the same niche like oh my heck
I'm doing more concrete photos. One thing that I've noticed too that I've done is if you get a client that's in your backyard
Go and go and send one of your people or you yourself take a camera
Take your iPhone go and take a bunch of photos go to one of their job sites and go get a bunch of photos
now you have to be a little bit careful because if you live in a climate that's like
Different like for example, I live somewhere. There's red rocks or stucco houses
It's like a very specific type of climate I could use those photos probably in Phoenix maybe in Vegas, right?
But I'm not gonna be able to use those photos to
Market in Montana because the houses the trees the landscape it's all gonna be different, but I will go to job sites
I've sent my team to multiple job sites to go and take photos and that gives me a bunch of photos
I can use not just on that project, but on future projects in the same niche. Okay